[Music]
whoa howy folks Maxell McGee here coming
to you with another episode of now
playing with me on the couch today Carol
bring bring a little too much Thunder
for you a little bit I wasn't I wasn't
prepared for that it is 2 o'cl in the
afternoon and what is it Wednesday it is
a Wednesday it's too much excitement for
a Wednesday yeah save it up for for July
4th save it up Friday Hol up that's
right it's almost almost time to light
some fireworks and and barbecue some
stuff right the American way we're going
to light some fireworks of our own I
like that I like that I was wondering
where you were going to lead me with
that in Zombies monsters robot zombies
monsters robots the game that you're
seeing on your screen right now is a
free to-play competitive Cooperative
third person shooter that is in open
Beta now you can actually go play it
right now or you can hang out and watch
me play it for the next hour
oh God I know what have I signed up for
I didn't sign up for this I didn't ask
for this I didn't ask for this um I'm
just going to jump right in yeah so I
have to say like this is the first time
I'm seeing zombies monsters robots it's
a title that I've heard uh bandied about
the office okay because you know you you
have games that have zombies you have
games that have monsters games with
robots but rarely do you come to a do
you come across a game that has zombies
monsters and robots I mean you may have
robot zombies you may yes you may have
monster zombies sure you may have what's
the other combination then monstrous
robot sure but see so with a title that
this D with the title that goofy I was
expecting a game that initially looked
kind of goofy also not this game looks
like a serious this game this game takes
itself seriously serious business and we
are going to spawn in so I'm actually
pretty sure I can either wait and see if
my team makes it to the next wave which
they might changing I mean they might or
I can go ahead and spend one of my oneup
tokens you notice down there in the
corner of course I can cash one of those
in to revive myself and join the game
immediately so I'm going to go ahead and
do that cuz I've got 43 of them I've
also got some sweet SWAT gear because I
wanted to look like the coolest kid on
the playground so I spent some in-game
currency and got myself sweet D okay so
so obvious so this is a free to-play
game very much though uh you can press
the F button to totally melee dudes now
so you said it's it's competitive and
Cooperative so so you're so right now we
are we're playing we're playing PV
Cooperative PVE right now um there is a
separate there's like a whole separate
set of lobbies for player versus player
that we'll check out later um yeah the
PVP or the PVE rather so far has just
been a lot of shoot your way through
waves of enemies and complete you know
objective so in in in this uh battle
that we're currently witnessing there
are as far as I can tell no zombies no
monsters and no robots are you blowing
this game wide open I mean I'm just
saying you just blew this game wi I'm
just saying is all you know I think
later on yeah we may see a few robots a
few okay sadly I do not believe there
are any
zombies or Monsters I guess that's
another thing yeah just hold on a second
okay what is the difference yeah between
a monster and a zombie are zombies I
mean I agree monsters well let's go
ahead let's just get this out of the way
right now this is a philosophical
debate Bonito has very good point that
we're about to touch on my thought is
that zombies are are they a
classification of monster or are they
their own seu I don't know if I consider
un undead
humans monst like when I hear the term
monster I think of something like a
something that looks more like a like a
cave troll from a you know like a Lord
of the Rings movie or something like
something that's kind of
not not not a human not so human anyway
it can be humanoid yeah but it has to be
further from like a normal human form
than a zombie is I mean are you talking
purely in the physical shape of the
monster or does it have something to do
with the fact that zombies were once
humans I I don't know cuz I I guess I
would say that a werewolf is a monster
okay and that you know werewolves are
were once human but I feel like the form
they can also go back to be yeah but I
feel like while they're werewolves to me
that's that is a kind of monster but for
whatever reason a zombie is just like an
undead
human and that to me does not a z a
monster make
oh that's a good idea uh I'm not sure
all right I'm pretty sure I would not be
able to look that up without having to
leave my game but as I have just started
I could go ahead and leave if people did
want to
join I guess I will go ahead and do that
I will abandon my team and therefore
waste that Revival token that I SP okay
right right this is all right so where
am I let's oh my God look at all this so
basically if you log on uhhuh and you
choose player versus environment
Cooperative PVE uh you'll see a list of
servers one of them is labeled as busy
the rest of them are pretty much open
okay I'm in the busy one I'm in the one
that everybody else is in at the very
top of the list so if you join that one
it'll bring you to this screen so from
PVE busy server it'll bring you to this
screen and then I am just going to check
show available only and we'll take a
look here I was doing Big Damn Heroes oh
looks like they're having some trouble
now that I left so I'm going to try to
get in on help this poor guy out poor
one out of five um but I'll be in this
one this
slid slim day uhhuh that'll be my room
your room slim slim
D me and this lady right here what's up
uh
oneup level seven
guy of course I'm playing as big Hank uh
noodle legs in the in the chat asks
where do the oneup tokens come from okay
so the account that I'm playing on right
now is a it's not like a special account
the developers gave me or whatever I
just went to play
zmrc okay play zmrc and just created an
account just like any of you would out
there and basically after you do there's
like a couple of tutorial missions um
and after you finish all man she's just
in there all by after you finish the uh
like three or four of the tutorial
missions it'll give you a sort of like
oneup coin Redemption token and then you
just go in your inventory you redeem
that and it gives you a whole bunch of
oneup tokens I started with 50 and I've
used a couple of them as you can see
yeah um I'm not after that I imagine you
would either unlock them over time or
would have to go into the shop to buy
some I'm almost certain you can go into
the shop and buy some I'm just not sure
how else you would earn them but we will
invest get that further after we finish
this all right so oh and there's some
robots those are yeah robot spider
creatures yeah I'm going to jump in help
her out big Hank on the scene and we've
also got
Tonka Tonka trucks coner power one thing
I do kind of like about the way this oh
we're coming in this backwards actually
this so I played this once before and
this was actually the extraction point a
helicopter came down to this helipad and
we got now we're coming in it in reverse
one thing I do kind of like is
everything is on the space bar going
into cover is on the space bar also
rolling is on the space bar um holding
down the space bar makes you run um so
all of your main you can also quick turn
by pressing back in the space bar
sometimes when you're good at it I'm
like ammo pickups all right goad no so
people are asking about the uh like what
your impression is of the free to-play
model here someone asked um you know is
it is it pay to win you know how much or
how much if you do just jump in and want
to play without spending money how much
are you limited you know by that I mean
right now so I'm not sure if this is how
it'll be in the final game but since the
game is in open Beta basically when I
created my account in addition to
getting this token for all the different
Revival coins they also gave me a
substantial amount of in-game currency
um so like right away like I was able to
buy this ridiculous SWAT outfit I bought
this shotgun that I have with me I
bought a couple of weapon mods and stuff
I was able to buy a whole bunch of stuff
right away so if you just want to go in
and check it out you're not going to be
you're not going to be bottlenecked
right up front
um beyond
that I would imagine it quickly gets
pretty
dicey um but again that's just something
that's something we'll see for ourselves
here in just a bit um but I mean at
least I've played it for a couple of
hours basically and so far the game has
been pretty generous with its giveaways
now whether or not that's going to hold
true once they come out of open Beta
remains
yeah um but it actually does I'm not it'
be interesting to see if all of my
equipment carries over into PP cuz I
like I said I bought some some some
higher level weapons and weapon mods and
stuff um and that's all available in the
store like you can use your in game
currency you can go in there we were
looking at before the stream started and
they've got all manner of high powered
weapons and weapon mods and Special ammo
types and things for you to pay real
money dollars for
um but again that might be something
that's only limited to player versus
environment and not available in PvP but
we will see in just a um but if that is
the case if it is available in PvP then
it is a very much pay to win kind of
scenario oh it's this room we're going
to be in this room for a while by the
way okay things things in this game
things in this game take a long time to
complete there are these waves are long
and
grueling that guy I'm going to try to
work on this window I guess done with
the windows I hope we just finish the
room after I complain about how long it
going to
take F
button something else that's kind of
neat though is you can also even if you
don't go out and buy a whole bunch of
weapons you can also pick up weapons off
the ground okay you don't keep them
after the mission's over but it's fun to
kind kind of mix it up yeah as you're
going
through these flamethrower guys are a
barrel of fun um their flamethrowers
actually look way more intimidating than
they really are right um they're more of
just sort of the idea of a flamethrower
rather than a real ethal get cone of
fire once this is out I'll drop it and
it'll be gone
forever burn up these dudes come out of
this monster
closet one of the enemies is putting the
smoke down on me trying to confuse
everything thankfully I don't believe
there's any friendly fire or at least I
haven't noticed any cuz I'm just not
being careful right now just having a
real hard time lining up those sniper
shots me clowning around over here these
Shield guys are the worst extremely hard
to kill somebody had actually involves a
little bit of teamwork to bring him down
oh not going in
there
private property okay not happening
employees only employees
only Sky mile Plus members may use the
airport
lounge
not
grades did we come to a consensus uhuh
on our zombie robot debate monster
zombie monster debate well I don't know
if if a consensus can be reached here M
I mean some of us will have to probably
agree to disagree I mean this is just
something you know my gut just tells me
that zombies are not are not monsters I
mean I have always believed a zombie to
be a monster they are a monsterous thing
they certainly they they're so I I've
always equated them sure
they're I mean they're mon they're
they're monstrous what if okay what
about this what about this what about
this what if if you had a zombie
bear okay well that was a z zombified
bear you're really getting me to think
about this question in in exciting new
ways you're kind of challenging my New
Dimensions my whole philosophy here get
into that world view and change my
change zombie world view we need to
cross the
catwalks access the I would I would
certainly I would say a zombie be a
zombie bear
okay yeah that would be that that would
qualify as a monster for me definitely
okay but I mean that's I guess bears are
already pretty close to being monsters I
mean if I see if I'm like on a camping
trip or whatever and i' see a bear I'm
like oh [__] what is that what is that
monster over there I know look at that
monster it's a monstrous yes creature a
monstrous
thing so is it a is it a once human
always human kind of thing then
well I I I don't want to I don't know
about that because I do feel like a
human could maybe be mutated into into a
monster
um Joe over here just take
it yeah
like I mean like so is so for instance
in in in The Last of Us M you have some
enemies that like have that that that
bacteria plant F yeah and the fungus
thing and I forget what they're called
but there are like a particular type
that's like really like large and
formidable and that you know to me like
that that would be a monster like those
are monsters but you're pretty pretty
far removed from your human Shell at
that
point
yeah apparently don't care too much mace
guy always cares he always wants to some
wh at every
opportunity is a that is a mean looking
mace so uh just to answer the question
from eais Roy in the chat we are playing
for anyone who uh may have joined us
late we are playing zombies monsters
robots zombies monsters robots which is
now in open Beta yes you can check it
out now at Play
zmrc
and we have opened the door and made it
across the catwalk I'm going to
grab a likes to teleport you to the area
that the rest of your party is if you
fall too far behind I like that maneuver
your guy does when he starts getting
shot and you're out of cover he duck the
head down like this I feel like really
it probably would not be that much maybe
cuz I've got the helmet on yeah yeah
yeah might bit of benefit right but if
you're just running around and the
bullets are
flying knocking your head Down's not
really going
to so this is sort of a two-pronged
attack by the enemies here these little
guys are going to pretty much infinitely
come out of this door while guys flank
us on the sides I'm going to keep
forgetting to do active reload this game
very much has oh actually went down yeah
it definitely has that the you know
Gears of Wares active reload thing going
on
uhoh oh they are chowing down on me real
good actually most oh look at my dead
solici I have seen too much oh no that's
actually surprising most of the time
whenever I get killed I just get killed
outright maybe if if you get taken down
by a melee attack you go into a down
state because when you're in a down
state somebody can run up and revive you
and you don't have to cash in one of
your sweet survival tokens yeah to do so
so that's you're out of the mode at that
point unless you you use a Revival token
you're out of the mode uh it seems like
you're out of the mode either until you
use a Revival token or your team like
until this happens basically and your
team sort of advances to the next thing
I see um but that can take a very very
long
time um now as far as the active reload
goes do you know if um and the game well
one more thing to that the game will
actually it will also autoboot you if
you're dead for too long yeah
just to come and their Lu but what can
is if your team super slow and you're
waiting to you know you don't want to
spend your token and you're just waiting
to be revived you can get Auto booted
before they reach the next
checkpoint and would have automatically
brought you back to which is unfortunate
when it happens you have to those I
think uh you know too frequent viewer of
uh GameSpot live streams Bob
Jones is now in there with you to see oh
wait Bob got kicked oh okay well he's a
real son of a be so probably for the
best we'll see you soon Bob maybe I
don't know what did he do did he even do
anything or did he just get kicked on
site I'm not really sure he's friend of
friend of the chat B yeah
absolutely oh man somebody is bringing
the
heat that guy you get oh I just I threw
a frag on top of us and did not melee
that guy that was my
bad oh he died and you didn't save him
oh well there you go apparently he he
had a a John mlan look going on for what
the the time he was in in the game
supporting a tank top and what not
unfortun that is like the the default
that is the default character look is
the tank top and sweet blue
jeans um cuz who doesn't love a tank top
is yeah um so I probably got him mixed
up with l Lally everybody
else I believe my charact oh no my
character's name is Big Hank you see big
Hank oh good it's this oh good it's this
robot I love this robot he's my favorite
Metal Gear Metal
Gear no
machines this robot's got lots of red
bits on it yeah you know what you do
with those red bits shoot the red bits
oh you shoot them you shoot the red bits
up real good we'll worry about the
glowing yellow tube sticking out of the
ground here in just a second all right
right now we got to shoot these red bits
and turn them into orange
bits I believe the guy on the radio is
yelling at us to oh Dodge the uh Dodge
the missiles Dodge the missiles and
lightly get tilted with shot or with
machine just a light smattering just a
little like a a little massage really
yeah it's like a little massage machine
gun fire all right so we've got the
machine gun oh Dag na it okay okay
so this is the the one hit kill laser oh
[__] everybody stand behind the
cylinders and not get incinerated by the
one hit kill laser and now oh this guy
knows what to do he is on the money he
is on the money he's got the yellow two
oh you got yeah point for massive damage
we
did and now we're going to do that about
eight more times yeah except we don't
have to do the machine gun round anymore
because we broke the machine guns now
it's just the missile round and then the
smaller missile round here's the main
missiles
here they come and really at this point
there's nothing you can keep shooting at
the robot okay but there's really no
point to it because so these missile
turrets as you can see they get
destroyed yeah but that just stops them
for shooting missiles that round okay
they will Auto Repair in the next cycle
so it's basically just a matter of
waiting until the until the weak point
yeah until the weak point shows back up
and using the uh the rocket
too this guy this guy is so on top of it
he's been here before
that he's going to wink at
us that we're doing pretty good though
we got a lot of one more maybe one more
round I think the last time I did this
actually it was like me and two other
people and that's probably why it took
so this time we got a we got a full
compliment here come the missiles again
out of the way
that again everything's on space bar
very
convenient I always forget about the
particle
laser the guy also comes on the radio
every time and goes avoid the particle
laser grab some
cover good thing you have such a capable
Co I know he is on top of it yeah on the
B
oh get it get it yeah all right now you
might think oh good yeah it's over
Victory yes but no no not by a long shot
oh we're like
halfway through okay turn to the LZ
that's right cuz we're done good work we
home we're pulling the troops out and
we're going home some more ammo a
mission accomplished I'm of course using
the what is it I'm going to call it the
Famas the Frank Adams Memorial assault
rifle oh the Frank Adams Memorial
assault rifle we love you Frank enemy to
cut off EV stay sharp stay Sharp
shooting dudes in the
hallway now sweet desert camo blue
camouflage guns guy up
here looks a lot cooler than I do you
have a sweet gas
mask all I've got is I got this stupid
SWAT helmet it's a lot better than this
dude wait is this Bob Jones maybe ah is
he back in I don't know if he's back in
I don't know Bob did Bob Jones tell us
what his name was if he did I missed it
unfortunately
that is you Bob you're doing the Lord's
work oh grenaded us
my throw some grenades back up slowly
got a lot
of oh oh hey does it oh you can make him
bleed I can make him
bleed if it
bleeds Carn yeah I know this may be a
bit of a stretch okay does this game
remind you of anything remind me so I'll
tell you there have been one or two
comparisons in the chat to to Gears of
War oh really yeah yeah yeah I would say
there's definitely you know a touch
little just a smidgen some inspiration
taken perhaps sure sure the Gears of War
um sadly I have not seen any chainsaws
or guns with chainsaw attachments though
I do believe I can buy like a Bowie
knife attachment for one of my guns okay
so that's you know that's
something um so just so you know uh Bob
Jones in the game was Bob Jones 198 oh
of course it was I like those monsters
cuz they look like they explode in
confet well if he comes back we'll be so
you're not Bob Jones this Bob Jones
impersonator yeah you want to go you
want to
dance you didn't want to dance optional
zero asking is this a free-to-play co-op
game or something wow you are a keen
right on the money Observer you nailed
it you nailed it optional zero but not
only is a co-op yes it is also player
versus player as we will see yes as soon
as we complete the rest of the
quest also this is definitely one of the
longer I think the the elevator's almost
here we're waiting for this elevator to
come down the game will actually it'll
just keep spawning enemies uhhuh um
until somebody gets on the elevator so
we could just hang out here forever if
we really wanted to and shoot bad guys
as they come down the hallway so are you
earning any kind of I guess in-game
currency as you as you take out these
monsters or definitely earning
experience um there is a leveling system
and that will also as you level up the
game will reward you with different uh
weapons and items and different unlocks
I know there's a uh I think I actually
unlocked the shotgun that I paid money
for at level three or four um so that
was perhaps not the wisest investment on
my part um but yeah you do love up um I
don't know if you're earning uh like the
the currency per se as you play but you
are definitely rewarded some
upon elevator get the hell out of
here on the elev stay on the elevator
thanks
boss remember Emeral hacket do you ever
play any of I was going to say no gear
did you ever play any of the mass effect
like Co-op multiplayer I actually didn't
play the Co-op multiplayer did get Park
command he would he would get on the
radio and he would never help with
anything he would just yell at you to go
pick things up and move them around or
to hack the data point or to do whatever
and I would play it with my friends and
we would always just just freaking
Admiral hack it you know it it sounds
really easy easy when you're up there in
the spaceship and orbit or whatever to
go take the node or to pick up the thing
and carry to the other thing but he
doesn't know what it's like he doesn't
know what it's like on the ground no no
exactly get down here get your get your
hands dirty we're dealing with Reapers
down here and banshees Banshee
Reapers they scream at you and impale
you unless you're playing as the guest
fonus says that uh suggests that it's
it's easy to miss the Gears of War
inspiration because it is carefully and
delicately
woven the original work of art it is the
unique zombies monsters robots oh um you
know I will neither confirm nor
disconfirm um scrill asking is this more
of a co-op game or a multiplayer Death
Match it's both two literally games in
one multiplayer death match in it which
we will see there's actually also one of
the things that that's new and that I do
want to check out before we finish up is
there is a yeah I you're looking why
doing the head down thing why you're up
there just shoot him if you wanted to
put your head down just get back and
cover oh my God great there is a
class-based multiplayer mode that uses
different so instead of just using like
your whatever character with his
whatever load out yeah there are
different classes with special abilities
um and there's like a team there's a
team zombies and a team humans and yada
yada yada and we'll check that out in
just a second I think that's that's
actually a recent
addition what's up spider dude get
wrecked I will say much to my
disappointment I mean we were talking
about the hers of War inspiration oh
sadly when your characters do go down
yeah they do not yell revive me a man um
you can crawl around a little bit as we
I did a little bit of crawling around
but sadly no no guttural Rev needs to be
found now the last time I did this the
game really put the screws to us right
here at the very end cuz it knew we were
about to get up on the path and just
started infinitely spawning gigantic
dudes just out of thin air walk our way
is that your Escape helicopter that is
our Escape helicopter up there one of us
just needs to get to it and we'll be
done so I'm going to go ahead and make
the Mad Dash for it although sweet do
see this is what it starts to do this is
what it starts to do all right we're in
the yellow in the yellow oh we're going
for it we're going for it no no oh but
somebody else somebody made it my
sacrifice was not in vain okay made it
to the
helicopter I like that you know I like
the Left for Dead thing
where you some people can make it and
others won't they'll fly off they'll
name a school after exactly I always say
that oh yeah name an elementary school
after me just you know just carry on my
legacy cuz we all have to go at some
point hey you were to Target D here we
go so I'm no longer an intern I'm now
Target dny I get the lmg fiberglass
stock but for three days don't okay no
no no don't go nuts don't go nuts over
here just get test drive it we've got
the Silver Bullet as well I wonder what
that is and also so 3500 gold that is
the that is the not real money in-game
currency is the normal acent in-game
currency I also have a mission that I
completed and I unlocked this gun turret
Mission punch the clock
so I guess that had something to do with
Mele press V to set down uh statman
snake asking this game on ps4 no it is
only on PC personal computer yes
personal computer Entertainment System
right um so a few calls for the Merks
versus monsters mode right I think that
was the one I was talking
about oh we're going to oh we're going
to take a quick break I'm going to go
ahead I'll switch over the server and
whatever to get to the appropriate mode
that you guys wanted to see but we'll be
right back after these
words welcome back whoa see that wasn't
so bad while you were gone we switched
over to the Merks versus monsters mode
and as you can see I'm a spooky monster
you are I am oh I'm also so let's see
this is the best walk animation look at
how good this
is It's like a Hugo walk from Street
Fighter ah oh but I don't have my role I
guess cuz I'm
all right so I believe this is like the
lowest level uh zombie this is the
zombie trooper I believe it's called um
I'm not sure this is actually my first
time in merch versus monsters I'm
familiar with the concept get this robot
and I
died down real real fast all right I
have no it would cost zero points for
this I have a thousand oh that took too
long
to get out here and see if we can do a
little bit better this time do I have
any kind of
doesn't
really is that a player that that uh is
this our robot or a bad guy
robot waale on a little bit see oh no
his name's in red we're going to wh on
although maybe maybe he's our buddy this
guy doesn't seem to be our
buddy be a dog this time I have
explosive suicide I'm down with
that look at how awesome this is this is
pretty great oh I okay okay oops so
Caroline yes Max what happened there
talk us through what happened fun fact
yes alternate fire is the explosive
suicide
ability fun fact oh look at this dude he
is TR all right so at first I
thought okay the green dots are going to
be my friends the red dots are going to
be my enemies I'm going to look to the
radar cuz it looked like I was getting
shot at by a monster and I had just
assumed that all monsters were friends
and all robots were enemies this weet
dude
dead get in here and see if I can blow
up on somebody maybe
this hey
buddy I'm sure he found that
entertaining hopefully let's try a
different guy this exploding dog isn't
working
out all right we've got archery dude I
think I can handle
that archery dude with sweet
Shields looks like what is the what is
the HUD tell you Carol what is our goal
here what do you what do you see well I
see I see some points I see kills
being uh tracked so I would imagine
kills are valuable play until you hit
the kill threshold oh who shot me going
back to Trooper oh look at this
dude I wonder if these points are shared
across the entire team or if they're
just for me speciic right now this is
the best running
I know earlier we thought that other run
animation was the best run animation but
this one is actually the
best guys have the right
idea see
now this this is more what I expect a
game called zombies monsters robots to
look like I wasn't really sure cuz the
other what you were doing before looked
kind of like a generic near future
military shooter kind of deal but this
has got
zombies and kind of robots maybe more
like cyborgs but I don't want to split
hairs here this oh no that's a spider
web not actually a cloak enemy it's
getting a little
paranoid you know I should probably
stick with some this guy's
doing guy what throws bombs everywhere w
we are
victorious wow we are victorious wow
carollyn wow
wow we are victorious this guy likes
him let's try that again see if we can
do a little
better we all seem to get along pretty
well we got a good thing going except
for that guy no incept for her there
and her I'm not this
guy sweet camo gas mask dude there must
be his
brother make kills to earn points earn
points to unlock
differ oh now we're on the Mer's
team go
here
so this yes so your gear from the the uh
the other mode doesn't carry over to
this right doesn't doesn't look like it
for this mode though this mode may be a
special circumstance since it is all
predetermined classes yeah yeah um but
we'll we'll take a look we'll do some
team death match after this
see it up
okay
spooky oh oh oh oh oh we got something
we got a live one over
here oh good oh good everybody is on
team humans and two people are on Team
Monsters
now this could be a one-sided
competition okay now another one maybe
they're slowly starting to trickle in if
I knew how to switch teams there we go
okay well they're they're figured
out this is a little one-sided now can
we completely spawn Camp them are they
all going to come out from under this
area yeah I guess they
are this we dude oh no I'm not getting T
oh no exploding dog see that's how you
do it that's how that's how the old
exploding dog trick works that's right
that exploding dog knew what it was
doing yeah knew just how to
explode you know I think you might need
to play this a little bit experience the
Majesty okay oh there is
a gravel no there's not gravel that
dude's an invisible
robot that is one of my favorite parts
of the freet to-play business model that
I think gets overlooked by a lot of
people is the looking at other people
and feeling jealous about the things
that they have yes it's an important
part yeah
up and the free toplay experience yeah
you know you look at them and you're
like you know what have I done with my
life I don't have that that guy looks
awesome maybe if I had worked a little
harder ah
Revenge let him know that I'm really a
horrible monster in real life whoa okay
never mind theage yeah well we're about
to get it back cuz I'm going to play as
one of those sweet invisible
robots oh dude that is look at how good
this
is got I've got high fives high five
people that dude's pretty a
too high five this
dog and I can throw blue energy
sphere they filled out pretty well hint
guys back in there too
oh you're going to charge oh he charged
you is that just like a one hit I
figured a
robot not expect a hulking robot to go
down quite so
easily all right next time I see giant
fat what charged this dude yeah not
going to just stay I'm not going to run
straight at him I'm going to mix up my
tactics just a little
bit dude never mind I apparently need to
go back to PVE although he just got
lach all right planing is super
conservative
now watch the
radar would be like the
win now are we the orange emblem or are
we the green emem uh you're are we
somehow winning in spite of my ability
to get run over at every
opportunity okay here's
this
okay you're cool you're cool you're cool
you're not you're going to do something
to me it's going to be bad you're going
to get hung up on the
geometry ah all right there you go
scored some points there scored some
points that really might have been more
of a technicality but I will take
it oh what's up what's up what's up dude
no what's up with
party oh no this turned into a bad scene
this turned into a bad scene oh man that
that got real ugly real fast it did get
real ugly real fast who do we not play
who we not play guy with Shield here we
oh it's metal shock Stick Dude oh hey oh
live the dream that's right how the
tables turned you've been on the
receiving been on the receiving end too
long yeah met shock oh well guess robot
guy with Shield is cool
too steal my
thunder person doing doing doing ow
zombie robot
lady what the hell she just pushed that
dude down he just pushed him over and he
fell no she's
gone this guy run straight at
me now I wonder if my shield oh he's
going to no's the tree block him
ah you get dude the way that you just go
down in this game it just doesn't feel
like feel
right
well in fighting look Carolyn yeah I
don't know what kind of crazy imaginary
world you come from are the win but when
a giant zombie fat zombie monster
charges you uhhuh oh this just goes it's
your right back in it I you know if it
ran me over I don't think I'd be getting
back up fair enough is all I'm saying
fair enough but also you are not a uh
hulking dude with a shield and a sweet
electrified mace thing you are a you are
flailing running zombie though I think I
got a kill you did and then I died I'm
going back to exploding dog I feel like
I really didn't get to explore the
nuances yeah no exploring dog is great
exploring dog he's really good he's
really good he's so explody he's really
explody I kind of wish the whole game
was just dudes with Pistols versus
Zombies with awesome run animation I
really like that set up oh this I don't
like this set up though bailing on
this walk over here this
guy oh come
on no one more again do it again we're
do don't judge
me
now I wonder when I explode on death
does that also cause damage or is it
just my death animation I would imagine
it it I would hope it would cause damage
to anyone standing
there nope no no that guy got that guy
got that
guy oh I'm I'm saving up for the big one
we're going to go we're going to do the
big guy I think this is dude what throws
exploding yeah exposive
Rock so two kinds of explosive
rocks actually I think this is just swi
this one is
explosive all right here we go here we
go R from oh wait a minute wait a minute
that was that was an invisible
robot I don't need to be spending money
I need to be earning oh that is so
expensive it's like way more expensive
than any the other one okay I don't know
if I'm going be able to save up for the
big gu but I'm going to try
not doing that back
up engage from
a against my old foe dude with Shield
all
right then this guy yeah he can throw
Spears oh he's the zombie shield guy
just th Spears oh nice
oh
dude yeah I no party
time 84 to 80 the humans with a slight
lead over the monster but
maybe my massive size
turn we shall
see maybe that hit him yeah nice y that
totally did hey what's up bud get
stabbed you get stabbed he got me what
am I up to now 8,000 I might be able to
get to a good enough score by the end
what 16,000 yeah it's 16,000 yeah so I
need like well just under 10,000
more will be easy easy
right I guess this is just the party
house for this entire
M this guy is Boom th000 points load up
again we're doing all it's all exploding
exploding dog is the most fun
cool you sure you don't want to get in
on this I yeah you know I'm I'm content
to
watch how much time do we have I feel
like as
uh I don't know uh are we I me I meant
more in the match but also in the Stream
as well well the match has five minutes
and 48 seconds remaining o that guy up
maybe it's a little
vague Caroline on a completely unrelated
note sure uh oh that guy up maybe hurt
him basically okay hold on I want to see
something so every time I've exploded
yeah let's go ahead and just explode oh
no they didn't give me anything okay
every time I've exploded it's giving me
a th000 points so maybe CU you're doing
D thinking like is it just cuz I'm dying
no okay it must be because I'm dealing
some amount of
damage yeah here we go let's just Farm
it up Let's Farm it up you're getting
there Peter and I had the best idea the
other day did you watch I mean did you
watch a lot of anime growing up no not
so much to to be honest okay well as you
may not remember uh-huh uh watching
anime on VHS tape was the coolest thing
to do I did a I did a little bit of
that mostly because you could pay like
$30 uh I'm sure a lot of people in chat
remember this well you could pay $30 get
yourself three episodes of Dragon Ball Z
okay right which was a steal at $10 an
episode right and you know watch it yeah
and if you wanted like I mean a you know
a season or whatever of a show would
take up like you know three feet of
that's right
whole because of course you know it's
like 200 episodes long so you got in
three episodes per tape so that's your
entire room yeah um so what we were
thinking is starting a business
where cuz you know they have anime and
it's like on DVD and Blu-ray and stuff
and it's like this is not the way it was
meant to be
seen we were thinking we'll start a
business of we have you know our DVD or
blue play or whatever set up and we'll
hook up a vcr and we'll record the anime
onto VHS cuz that's the experience
people are looking for some people like
to watch Subs some people like to watch
dubs I like to watch on lowquality VHS I
like you know you like to have the
little have to do the tracking every now
and then you know it's everything's a
little bit fuzzy sometimes it does like
this thing where like flickers up and
down it's more uh kind of user
participation experience right cuz you
kind of have to get involved a little
bit tweak some things you to play with
it a little yeah yeah yeah
yeah of course only three episodes per
tape and we would charge a huge huge
overhead well just you know again to
maintain the authenticity of the
original experience I mean in addition
to selling anime we're also selling you
know a piece of nostalgia Bob Jones 1980
still has his DBZ VHS T nice yeah good
for you Bob Jones I'm trying to think do
I what do I still have I feel like I
purged a lot of that a long time ago and
now I of course completely regret it I
had some DBZ
tapes guess it was just mostly DBZ tapes
and like things that I recorded just
straight off of the
TV going back to PVE yeah I was that out
again it was a real rough time mhm in
the PV oh wait no we were going to check
n hold on we were going to check team
death match to see if I I can use my bot
weapons and team
death leave the people hanging we what
is Ladder mode oh it's
full okay well
they're well I mean we have kill
everything which you might think be
would be enough but no kill
kill depending on your Let's do let's do
a little
T
oh hot damn big damn Heroes oh Big Damn
Heroes is the one you were doing big is
the one I did but how damn looks awfully
that that Rubble field hallway looks
awfully
familiar what about
this haven't seen before all right
these two dudes who did not bother
spending money on sweet SWAT
camo go ahead and show oh there's going
to be zombies in this
one dou double
damage like to hear here we go let's
cash in those revive tokens and jump
right in there you go look at that look
at that what is
that what even is that Frank Memorial
assault
rifle so it looks like this is going to
be so this was actually this looks
similar to one of the training missions
that I did so it's like barricades uh
and zombies are going to run up to the
barricades start knocking them down sure
sure you kind of repair the barricades
and stuff I'm not sure oh is that dog
going to explode okay no it didn't not
sure if we get to repair the barricades
okay all I know is oh yeah we do let me
just uh get the old monkey wrench here
don't mind me just getting a little work
done just doing the Lord's work this guy
head
good to go good to go I like that look
at this cool
dude
classic uh zombie Hospital
Motif this is the best there we go just
like doing this thing just Hammer back
up just make it look like he's working
on
it uh-oh what that's something something
happen did you catch
that feel like you're not giving the
attention well the chat the chat is just
so mesmerizing are they blowing it up
are they blowing it up in
chat they ruining all the work I
did dogs sweet dogs F button from a
everybody gets a high five you get a
high five you get a you don't you don't
you don't get a high five
yeah yeah Carn what do you think of my
of pet and I our anime VHS Tye idea cuz
I really feel like this has got legs I
feel like yeah this is the this is the
way I could open up an an Etsy page yeah
see and that'll be my whole thing yeah
well I mean I think you'd have to pay
give some serious thought to packaging
right I mean because the the box art
and was was a kind of an important part
of the experience as well it was having
a sweet B and you get like the two like
kind of blurry screenshots on the back
there from your episode yeah so exactly
so I think if you if you get that part
of it down then you might really really
have something what kind
of what do you what do you think what
kind of C expenditure I
mean VHS tape is pretty old yeah
um but then again you're just making
like a little cardboard sleeve like how
much is something like that going to
cost
well
I mean I I'm ordering against bulk also
yeah I mean for yeah production I mean
the the production of these things I
mean because there there can't be a big
Market these days for production of VHS
packaging right it might kind of a so
the people who are doing that for you
might be able to charge something of a
premium right because there's you know
where else you going to go yeah um
unless you can find a way to do that in
house um but
think I could like I could like 3D print
something like that get your 3D printer
out and just pop pop a few of those bad
boys
out oh man we are getting all sorts of
stuff all of a sudden what is
happening got 200 credit
points oh cow not going in there gooo
riot in the chat oh gooo Riot what's
happening
says haha Maxwell's VHS idea is terrible
who would want that everybody that's
just one that's just one person's
perspective Max I I wouldn't put too
much too much St in such a good
idea don't let
naysayers how much money have people
spent buying like NES cartridges and
Sega Genesis cartridges and whatever I
buy that sort of stuff all the time
because someone can't see the potential
of your dream isn't a reason to to to
not believe in it Maxwell it just
doesn't make any sense
obviously you know it originally came
out on a VHS format that was the
original that was the intended way to
view it look you can download Super
Mario Brothers on the Wii or whatever on
the Virtual Console yeah but who wants
to do that it's no fun you got to play
with the Wii mode yeah it's so small
everyone know yeah it's just not the
game the game loses something if you
don't have to blow into an NES C TR 17
times when Moto was going around in
those caves behind his house coming up
with the Legend of Zelda yeah he wasn't
like oh boy I hope I make this game and
then people download it years later and
play with a teeny tiny controller and
everything's terrible no he wanted
people to play it on the cartridge with
the stuffff the way it was to be
played so if you want to go back and
watch you know your Sailor Moon and Your
Dragon Ball Z I don't want to hear about
Hulu I don't want to hear about oh it's
available free you can get on Netflix
streaming whatever red B no forget Red
Box you don't even get a box you just
get the sleeve that the disc comes in
thanks for
nothing great idea Caroline of course it
is Max I would never dream of saying
otherwise he got me all worked up I'm
sorry I never I never should have shared
goofi riots I can't I just I can't I
know I
know where are we now on these on Wave
seven is it seven of just until we die I
sure hope not
I I mean normally these modes you know I
think feel like they end it like 10 or
15 you know they pick a kind of a nice
round number number to yeah end on need
to get these
daggers double damage high five you get
high five you get high five oh it's a
little cool no it's a little froggy in
here so here red tone 6 asks regarding
your business idea Max my V my business
venture is looking to invest because I
still seeking Angel Investors for anime
sweet anime VHS before he I think he has
questions before he can answer that and
his question is now is would you
consider doing betamax tapes as well but
here's my thing about that is the
betamax format I think had kind of
already fallen by the wayside by the
before the anime boom happened in the US
right so I don't think that series like
Dragon Ball Z and so on were really ever
popularized or even available on the
betamax format so that would kind of run
contrary to the whole Spirit of I think
what your what Your Venture is that's
right I mean I personally I'm going to
have to take a hard stance on this I'm
going to have to go with a a if it came
out on that format
originally then that's something to
consider I mean I want to I want to
start with VHS just cuz that's what I'm
familiar with that's what I'm
comfortable with I want to start there
as sort of a jumping off point and then
you know if we pick up some traction
we're able to bring on some more people
like expand it a little bit then I'll
consider like oh okay we want to you
want you want to get some laser disc in
there you want to get some uh you want
to get some beta Max you want to get
some you know your what have you you
know we'll think about that but if the
show didn't originally come out on that
format then I really don't see the point
I because that I
mean I mean then where where do you draw
the line at that point yeah
exactly so I mean if you could you know
if he wants to check and you know you
could tell me if it did come out on that
format thing yeah yeah we'll be happy to
put that on the on the old
to-do but otherwise I'm going to have to
you know have to agree to
disappear we just get in this elevator I
feel like it make our lives a
lot quiet please s neuros SLE testing
testing in progress neurot
testing people are not really on board
with
using feel like a real misstep
on or maybe it's
not yeah this kind of the idea of a
flamethrower yeah kind of you really got
to put your back flame are more in idea
than in
practice in practice it's really just
kind of a heat cone like one of those
lowlevel dungeon and dragon spells cone
of cold this is cone of
burn away that fog you
know looks like we are a minute 30
out from the end I guess I guess it's
just complete however much you can in
the time only be given no see cuz now
wave 10 started and the timer went away
so yeah it's just like you have to
finish each wave within a time limit
maybe it does Never End maybe I will
just end it after W or if the if it does
not if it doesn't have the decency to
end end at wave
10 then we will go ahead and put a fork
in
it you watch tunami
at me nooon DZ I mean it's really the
only things that could be classified as
anime that I've watched are films like
Miyazaki films uh you know Kira of
course I've seen Aira now did when you
saw a Kira did you were you able to see
it at the cool kids college campus some
sort of like some sort of screening on a
college campus uh yes in fact um that's
awesome I never got to do that yeah it
was it was actually required viewing uh
for uh yeah for a class that I took in
college and and it was shown in a proper
movie theater essentially on campus
um so yeah yeah that was that was pretty
CRA experence did I did I did a actually
the theater appreciation course I took
was one of my favorite courses in
college both because you got to watch
movies in class and because there was a
lot of interesting
discussion oh it did end at wave 10
hooray hey victory way to go we did it
and I'm glad that the game had the
decency to to end there to know that it
gone on gone on long
enough what time is it currently well
Max I'm glad you asked it is
3:2 here on the West Coast Pacific time
we're getting the wrap it up twisty
finger yeah folks thank you for spending
an hour of your time with us I'm Max M
here with Carolyn P we've been playing
zombies monsters robots which is in open
Beta right now and you can check out for
yourself at play zmrc drink a little
water oh that is good um I'm going to go
ahead and wrap it up okay you folks have
good rest of the week and have a safe
4th of July holiday have some fun but be
safe and we'll uh we'll see you next
time